- [Instructor] What I'd
like to do in this video
is a few more examples
recognizing the slope and
y-intercept given an equation.
So, let's start with something
that we might already recognize.
Let's say we have something
of the form y is equal to five x
plus three.
What is the slope and the
y-intercept in this example here?
Well, we've already talked about
that we can have something
in slope intercept form
where it has a form y
is equal to the slope,
which people use the letter m for,
the slope times x plus the y-intercept,
which people use the letter b for.
So, if we just look at this,
m is going to be the coefficient
on x right over there.
So, m is equal to five.
That is the slope.
And b is just going to be this
constant term, plus three.
So, b is equal to three.
So, this is your y-intercept.
So, that's pretty straightforward
but let's see a few slightly
more involved examples.
Let's say if we had
form y is equal to five
plus three x,
what is the slope and the
y-intercept in this situation?
Well, it might have
taken you a second or two
to realize how this earlier equation
is different than the one I just wrote.
Here, it's not five x, it's just five,
and this isn't three, it's three x.
So, if you wanna write it
in the same form as we have up there,
you can just swap the
five and the three x.
It doesn't matter which one comes first,
you're just adding the two,
so you can rewrite it as y is
equal to three x plus five.
And then it becomes a little bit clear
that our slope is three, the
coefficient on the x term,
and our y-intercept is five,
y-intercept.
Let's do another example.
Let's say that we have the equation y
is equal to 12 minus x.
Pause this video and see if
you can determine the slope
and the y-intercept.
All right, so, something
similar is going on here
that we had over here.
The standard form, slope intercept form,
we're used to seeing the x
term before the constant term,
so we might wanna do that over here.
So, we could rewrite this
as y is equal to negative x plus 12,
negative x plus 12.
And so, from this, you
might immediately recognize,
okay, my constant term,
when it's in this form, that's my b,
that is my y-intercept.
So, that's my y-intercept
right over there.
But what's my slope?
Well, the slope is the
coefficient on the x term
but all you see is a negative
here, what's the coefficient?
Well, you can view negative x
as the same thing as negative one x.
So, your slope here is
going to be negative one.
Let's do another example.
Let's say that we had the
equation y is equal to five x.
What's the slope and y-intercept there?
At first, you might say,
hey, this looks nothing
like what we have up here.
I only have one term
on the right-hand side
of the equality sign.
Here, I have two.
But you could just view
this as five x plus zero,
and then it might jump out at you
that our y-intercept is zero
and our slope is a
coefficient on the x term.
It is equal to five.
Let's do one more example.
Let's say we had y is
equal to negative seven,
what's the slope and y-intercept there?
Well, once again, you might say,
hey, this doesn't look
like what we had up here,
how do we figure out the
slope or the y-intercept?
Well, we could do a similar idea.
We could say, hey, this is the same thing
as y is equal to zero times x minus seven.
And so now, it looks just
like what we have over here
and you might recognize
that our y-intercept is negative seven,
y-intercept is equal to negative seven.
And our slope is a
coefficient on the x term,
it is equal to zero.
And that makes sense.
For a given change in x, you
would expect zero change in y
'cause y is always negative
seven in this situation.